I have a dream
[Music]
hey guys did you know that around 80% of
people experience some kind of minor
acne or pimples but some people have it
even worse because they do certain
things that causes more pimples and they
don't even know it so there's a lot of
information out there some are based on
truth and some are just myths and so in
this video I'm gonna tell you exactly
what causes pimples on your face and how
to prevent it let's get to it
too much sebum production now this is
the main cause of pimples and acne in
people's lives so what is it well
basically your hormones causes your oil
glands to produce too much sebum but
area then multiplies and gets more deep
in your pores then your dead skin cells
blocks it inside of the pore and also on
the surface and the result is you get
pimples so it's actually a form of
infection and that's why pimples are red
and sensitive and have that kind of
white puss at the top below so the best
way to handle this is first to use a
good water-soluble cleanser and second
use a good exfoliant with silicic acid
DHA which will remove those dead skin
cells and also fight the bacteria now I
use this guy from Paula's Choice which
is great you can also fight the bacteria
with benzoyl peroxide but if you stick
consistently to a good skincare routine
is gonna make a huge difference on your
skin and if you're not sure which
products to use I'll add a few good
options for you in a video description
down below so you can check it out
not washing your face after a workout
well working out is really good not only
for your body but also for your mind
right but if you don't wash your face as
soon as you're done with the workout it
will lead to more bacterial build-up and
temples
[Music]
over washing and scrubbing don't ever
try to over wash or scrub your face
crazy to try and get rid of pimples some
people wash their face every few hours
without realising that it can make their
skin to dry red and it can even start to
peel and it just causes a lot more
damage and also pimples wash it only in
the morning after workout and when you
go to bed reusing your washcloths if you
use your washcloth on your face day
after day of the day and you just leave
it there in the shower bacteria builds
up and then you come and you just put
that bacteria back on your face again
don't do that I don't even use your
washcloth on my face I just use my hands
because that's enough sleeping on the
same pillowcase without washing it I
mean if you do that and you sleep on
that pillowcase you put your face on it
between six to eight hours every day
bacteria builds up you don't wash it and
you keep your face in that kind of dirt
and oil and oh all right you might get
more pimples if you do it so start
washing your pillowcase more often at
least once or twice a week
too much sugar some people say no food
and sugar these things it doesn't really
cost pimples and other people say well
yes it does it's been an argument about
this forever
so what's the truth what is the research
say well recent study shows a direct
link between sugar and pimples sugar
causes your blood sugar and your insulin
to spike causing inflammation and also
excess sebum which then causes pimples
so yes sugar can give you more pimples
but apart from just pimples we know now
that sugar is one of the most dangerous
drugs out there in the world so stay
away from sugar look at your food labels
as well because the food industry is
very clever and now they almost add
sugar into everything you eat and drink
take care of yourself
stress now your body responds to stress
with physical emotional and mental
responses but stress itself doesn't
cause pimples but it can make it a lot
worse look we know that your age your
hormones and also bacteria causes
pimples right but recent studies also
showed that stress can also trigger acne
or make it even worse it's interesting
that as we advance in technology in the
age that we live in to make life easier
for ourselves it's actually doing the
opposite stress has now become a
worldwide epidemic and the suicide rate
is increasing so if you struggle with
stress take some time out from your busy
schedule and try to deal with it
remember you cannot control the outcome
of every situation so just do your best
and every single thing that you do and
then accept the outcome the quicker you
accept the outcome the quicker you can
move on don't spend too much time on
regretting the past but use that time to
deal with it in an effective way and to
move forward it's okay to fall to make
mistakes we all make mistakes it's okay
to to fail 100 times but it's not okay
to stay down you can't change every
situation that's impossible but what you
can change is the way that you think
about it now if you want to grow
stronger in mind and spirit then check
out my new channel here where I'll be
discussing a lot of these deeper issues
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and see me in the next
video
Cheers
[Music]